yeah we're gonna do two further examples
where you start with a little equation
but you don't get something linear out
the other end you end up with something
before tried it so let me distinguish
right this starts is a quadratic squared
but you in with something linear okay
lyndie okay lyndie here you just get two
parts that's why there are two solutions
but what I'm gonna show you is going to
end in a quadratic not start with one
fish to cure my choices what are we to
do this thing okay again you rack your
brain think about your log loss okay
what can we do with this left hand side
B that it's the sum of two logs yeah me
too okay fantastic when you add logs
when you add logs right those parts the
peak of the product it's exactly the
reverse of when you've multiplied
indices you add the powers so this is
going to be equal to three okay now this
this what we have here is more or less
what I have here it's just the inside
here I have a quadratic rather than just
the linear function right which is why
I'm gonna have to end up solving a
quadratic yet so if I put this down in
index for I'll do a couple of things at
once
number one I'll say okay this is going
to be base 2 to the power of 3 right so
I'm going to get 8 over there too cute
at the same time I might as well just
expand this because I'm gonna have to
work with it
that's x squared plus X so far so good
okay now I have to go ahead and solve so
this is what I've really got it doesn't
factorize nicely so you just launch it
to your formula okay
what are we gonna get stopped me on
minus 1 plus or minus square root of 1
plus because it's minus 4ac but I have a
double negative happening here so this
really should be plus 32 good all
divided by 2 2 n ok I'll just tidy that
up just a teeny little bit ok so because
I ended up with a 1/2 hand up because I
arrived at a quadratic I now have two
solutions quadratics have two solutions
but keep in mind but as we went through
this to get to this point I kind of
transformed my original problem into a
different one and then employ the
quadratic so when you transform the
problem we've noticed this before
whether it's using trig identities or
tears or whatever right you need to
check the original solution sorry your
original equation with this solution to
your I've done okay so when you have a
look at these two values minus 1 minus
333 Walla 2 and minus one plus three
thirty three months to do they both work
answer no they don't
just to be really I heard the numbers
here are easy enough that you don't need
a calculator but they weren't always be
as I'll show you in a minute let's do
these each so minus 1 minus root 33
divided by 2 so we just put
one of the solutions is - 3.37 okay the
other solution
she went yeah
to hear my own hear my chi values that
I'm ending up with okay now I don't need
to actually reach for my calculator
anymore when I look at these and think
about the original equation okay so for
instance let's have a look at this guy
with your 7 ok if you go ahead and put
this little bit would it make sense well
assuming that all about algebra and PL
was correct pretty sure it is
it should check out even though it's
some awful decimal it'll it'll actually
evaluate but when you take this other
value over here up right you immediately
run into a problem you media manager
problem your calculator will tell you
it's probably what really explain it
I'll just start to write the first thing
that happened you start to think about
this log base 2 of - 37 now before you
get your calculator and it just tells
you this doesn't work why doesn't this
work okay you're jack fantastic let me
say that again because the stock stand
response maybe some of you were thinking
about this well you can't take a log of
a negative number and that is true you
can't take the log of a negative number
because if you think about it this is
what the log curve looks like okay and
there are no it's not to fight maybe he
just nothing is over here right so
you've got an asset to here so your X is
greater than zero that's your
restriction and this is this is your C
you busted but really what it means
I'm so glad Jack said this first off is
this is about a period of time if it's a
long it's like I'm growing at around two
I'm W I'm W double it at what point in
time will I be this size and the answer
is
it doesn't matter how far you go forward
in the future and how far back you go in
the future you're very small but you'll
never get negative okay exactly the same
way that any initial further and further
and further in here and you'll never
actually hit zero let alone cross it and
become negative does that make sense
okay so therefore as we've mentioned
before is a scenic tree right actually
write the first line we missed something
we should have mentioned something as
soon as we wrote the first line there
are two restrictions in play for your
husband there's a restriction implied by
this function and restricted implied by
this one what are the restrictions for
each one first one first one is this
restriction right X has got to be
greater than zero that's the one
restriction implied by this right this
is a different function this looks
different right what's the restriction
applied by this X is greater than
negative one okay now when you have two
things in you like I need to satisfy
both of them otherwise the whole thing
is a sham okay so when I look at both of
these which one is on credit quote which
one is more restrictive which one
applies is more significant than
whoo let's think of it let's think of
some numbers okay
so for instance if I pick a number like
two okay or two point three seven that
satisfies both doesn't [ __ ] up okay if
I pick a number like one still good if I
pick a number like zero it satisfies
this one but it doesn't satisfy this one
can you see you see that so this one in
a sense it's kind of more peaky right so
this one overrides this one this one is
the really important research we need to
watch for does that make sense okay so
at that point I would say all right
therefore x equals only the positive one
as X is greater
happy with that